the bank of England says that we are  likely to be in recession this is  disappointing but not entirely  unexpected news and what we need to do  now is to present a plan to the country  to tackle the root cause of the issues  we face which is inflation and a plan  that protects the most vulnerable and  that's what I must do next Thursday when  we produced a fiscal statement that  didn't show how we were going to bring  our debts down over the medium term the  markets reacted very badly and so we've  learned that you you can't fund either  either spending or borrowing without  showing how you're going to pay for it  and that's what I'll do